hello tom
tom is an engineer on the planetary
computer team at microsoft he has
maintained several libraries including
desk and pandas and today tom will talk
about scalable sustainability with the
planetary computer
all right thank you uh yeah so uh let's
get started um first of all i want to
kind of set some context uh you know
where where i'm coming from
like why is someone from microsoft out
of pi data talking about sustainability
um and so
last a
year and a half ago or two years ago
microsoft made a few sustainability
commitments um these are things for like
their own business that they're
concerned about uh things like being
carbon negative water positive zero
waste by 2030 um i'll put links up uh at
the end but these are all links to the
announcements for these um
uh all these commitments uh and then the
last uh commitment here is uh around
protecting our ecosystems it's not some
concrete things like setting aside more
land than we use uh by 2025 uh and then
this last thing here is is build a
planetary computer uh and as you're
going through this list you know one of
these is definitely uh very different
from the others so uh things like being
carbon negative water positive zero
waste like that's you know very
concretely like uh acknowledging
microsoft's impact on the climate uh and
then uh really really interested in like
what the changing climate the kind of
risk that that poses to uh to our
business uh into the businesses of our
customers so you kind of see why we're
interested in things like this but this
last one around like building a
planetary computer you know what it what
is that uh planetary computer for a
sustainable future pretty picture uh
into the planetary computer it's this
nice uh term that we're using for
this thing that's like
it's it's worth recognizing that a whole
lot of sustainability problems they look
a lot like geospatial data analysis
problems where you have lots and lots of
of geospatial data coming in that people
want to use uh to make informed
sustainability decisions
um so that's that's essentially what the
planetary computer is it's like this
geospatial analysis thing to help people
analyze all this data for sustainability
if you break it into its components uh
the main thing uh that makes up the
planetary computer is the data catalog
so this is a whole bunch of data in
azure blob storage and nice analysis
ready cloud optimized formats that
people can just go and use
um it's like that's great that's a lot
of work we also have apis that we build
on top of that data to make it easier to
use and we'll see examples of that in a
minute
and then finally is the planetary
computer hub so this is like a
convenient environment where people can
go and do their analysis so this is
taking a lot of the lessons learned by
the pangeo community if you're familiar
with that group uh they've basically
been trying to do uh scalable geoscience
um mostly on the cloud not exclusively
uh and have been just like smoothing
over a lot of the rough edges figuring
out what works what doesn't when trying
to do
geoscience at scale
finally kind of recognizing that it's
not just doing data analysis for its own
sake all of these
all the data that we're putting there
the apis and the hub they're all kind of
in service of
sustainability decision making
so to that end we're partnering with
other groups
individuals to make
applications uh that use our data our
apis insights from from the hub to put
together uh higher level applications
that can then be put in front of
environmental sustainability decision
makers to help them make informed
decisions
um okay so diving into each of these
starting off with the uh data catalog
i'll just pause on this slide for a bit
because it's so nice to look at um every
time we bring on a new data set we get
to uh make like a thumbnail for that uh
so it's really
the best part of adding a new data set
so we have lots and lots of data like i
said in in azure blob storage so uh this
is uh nice uh kind of jumping ahead but
uh
we
blob storage it's like very scalable so
it's it's uh you can access it in
parallel from many machines if you have
really large problems so uh it's really
nice to be able to
rely on that scalability and that
parallelism and we don't want anything
in between your analysis and in blob
storage
and then we have it in cloud optimize
format so
depending on the type of data that's
going to look a bit different in the
case of
raster data like imagery remote sensing
data coming from satellites or aerial
photography or like elevation data sets
derived from
from that imagery those are going to be
stored in as cogs so cloud optimized
geotiffs
if you're not familiar with uh
geospatial data formats uh a
cog
cloud optimized geotiff is just a tiff
with some uh geospatial metadata in the
header that's been kind of uh internally
chunked in certain ways to make it
friendly for streaming over the web
but end of the day it's just like a a
tiff file so an actual image file in a
special format
for earth system science data so it's
like climate and weather models we're
using a lot of zar
so climate weather models they tend to
be higher dimensional than imagery uh
and so they're
they're best represented as chunked in
dimensional arrays and zar's a a great
format for that
and then finally for tabular data uh
we're mostly storing that in uh apache
parquet format and we have nice readers
like fastparkay and pyro for being able
to read that in in python but all these
are our all these storage formats are
language agnostic
uh and like i mentioned earlier we're
really focused on these cloud native
style workflows uh so part of that is
just putting the compute and the data in
the same region so this is something
that that pangea group has been uh
working on for a while now uh but
enabling these kinds of workflows make
it easy to set up compute in the same
region as the storage and then access it
in parallel stream data directly from
blob storage straight into memory either
on a single machine or possibly on many
machines as we'll see
okay uh so the next little section um we
saw the data catalog then we have the
api so in particular we're going to be
talking about stack the spatial temporal
asset catalog
and what it enables
before i get into what stack is it's
worth kind of uh
talking to like why is it helpful so
let's say you know we've gone through
all this work we've gotten this data
they're beautiful cloud optimized
geotiffs perfectly optimized and they're
in blob storage for you and then i ask
you to say okay give me all the uh cogs
that cover wyoming in 2016.
uh and you're looking through the the
list of cogs and blob storage and you're
like maybe opening up the python regex
documentation to see you know there's
dates in here somewhere it's like a lot
of dates i'm not quite sure there's
probably some geospatial like where on
earth this is but it's kind of not
exactly obvious just by looking at the
file path so you're probably going to
have to like open up these uh files with
rasterio and like figure out what's its
it's like coordinate reference system
what area it's covering things like that
so that's slow that's error prone if you
want to this is for landsat 8 if you
want to do the same thing for a
different mission like sentinel 2
that's going to have a different naming
scheme and so you have to like reinvent
all those um those heuristics to find
like how do i get just the ones that i
care about
so that's where stack is helpful
if you're with a stack api like we're
running here at
planetarycomputer.microsoft.com
you're able to use these client
libraries like pi stack client
and then that task of give me all the
images for wyoming in 2016 becomes very
easy i just asked for this landsat 8
collection collection 2 level 2 that
intersects with this wyoming geometry
geojson object and then um covering this
date time here this date range okay so
that's really what stack is enabled is
enabling
um in terms of what it actually is it's
this uh
specification uh for how to catalog the
metadata associated with geospatial
scenes uh geospatial spatial temporal
data
okay uh so the core stack specs says
basic things about like this scene this
image was captured at this date time um
and it covers this area things like that
and then there's a whole
list of extensions like what's the
projection information what area on
earth does it cover in that projection
things like that that's
built on top of stack and and we're
using for these workloads i'll show you
later on
in terms of this is way too small to see
but just kind of emphasizing that stack
is a metadata standard so it's taking
all of that metadata that's associated
with like a satellite image of the earth
and and putting it into a structured
form so it's all about the metadata uh
and then that is linking to the actual
uh assets themselves which might be cog
files they might be parquet data sets it
can be whatever but the actual uh stack
is just concerned with metadata and then
it has links out to the data files
themselves
so with all that structure we're able to
do some interesting things on top of it
it's like one interesting thing is
building that search endpoint um and so
that's what's that's what's powering the
search endpoint we're also able to do
things like uh build a nice uh html
catalog at uh
planetarycomputer.microsoft.com and the
explorer which i'll show if i have time
at the end
okay
so that's the data uh that's the apis
and then the last thing here is the
planetary computer hub uh this really is
um building up those lessons learned by
pangeo so i'll jump over it to it now
um and hopefully um
yeah so i'm logged in here to this uh
planetary computer hub uh and this is
just a jupiter hub deployment in uh
azure in the same region as the data
and it's enabled with dash gateway
so if you haven't used das uh gateway
before it's a way to
um have like the centrally managed das
clusters for users uh so i asked for a
gateway cluster here i scale it up to 64
workers
and then i'm ready to go
um so this first example we're going to
go through is uh computing a cloud-free
composite so when you're working with
satellite data the
like first thing you always run into is
at least for electro optical data is
you're gonna it's cloudy a lot of the
time on earth and that just kind of
ruins anything you're trying to look at
um so one common operation is to kind of
stack up these images in time and find
do like some kind of median to remove
the cloudy pixels
okay so using what we saw before we're
going to go to uh use our stack api here
and we're going to in this case use
sentinel 2
scenes to find
all of the sentinel 2 scenes that
intersect with our bounding box here so
this covers redmond washington
for this date time so 2016 to
the end of 2020
and where the
stack enables you to
catalog a whole bunch of information and
then the stack api lets you filter on
that so in this case we're going to
filter where the cloud cover as
determined by
esa the european space agency that's
running this mission where the cloud
cover is less than uh 25. okay so we can
run that and we quickly like in less
than a second or so we get back the 138
items that match our conditions
um so the api here uh this is you know
anybody can use this it's completely
public um uh anybody can make requests
to that uh the data files themselves so
the cog files those are in a private
blob storage account so if i just tried
to open up one of those urls i'd get
like a 404 error
so you do need to sign the urls before
you can access the data
and anybody can you can sign the urls
anonymously it just depends this
read-only shared access signature to you
to the urls uh and at that point it's a
regular uh url that you can open up in
any common tool qgis gdal rasterio
whatever um and yeah at that point it's
just a regular url uh we're gonna use a
tool called stack stack which makes it
easy to stack together a stack of stack
items um if you notice i ran that and it
was like very quickly uh returned the
outcome of this cell
so what stack stack was able to do is
quickly build up this x-ray data array
so we have our 138 time steps here
our three bands so we're grabbing a red
green and blue band
and then our x and our y coordinates so
stack stack is
building off of all of that stack
metadata
so it has things like the projection
information and the shape and size and
all of that it's able to use all that
metadata to construct this data array
without opening a single file uh a
single cog file which takes like a
handful of a few hundred milliseconds
maybe and when you have you know 138
times three that few hundred
milliseconds adds up
and then
so it's able to do that real quickly and
then we're actually persisting the data
so if you haven't seen das before this
is the task stream so the vertically
these are all of our workers here and
going to the right this is the activity
of a core on our uh cluster over time so
right now we're just reading data
essentially uh takes like six to nine
seconds maybe to read in a single cog
file
okay um and now we wanna do our our
cloud-free mosaic by taking a median
and so this will kind of collapse over
the time dimension before we add those
138 time periods we're going to take the
median at each pixel
and then convert that to a true color
image with the idea being um so the idea
behind the median is like uh things like
buildings and like hills mountains uh
roads they tend to not change much uh
pixel uh sorry uh snapshot to snapshot
over time but things like clouds will
come and go
uh so this is a pretty common way to
remove clouds uh from a pic from a
from a stack of images
okay so that's gonna carry on there
we're doing so for das when it does this
median there's a bunch of re-chunking to
get the
the time uh coordinate in in one chunk
uh and rechunking along the other
dimensions but uh it finishes up the
median pretty quickly and then now i
think we are we've moved on to
converting that um
that's a
3d array of of red green blue in
i think it's like floating point from
zero to a few thousand or something i
don't know exactly what the meaning of
those pixels are but
this x-ray spatial dot
true color will convert it to a rgb a
representation
at that point you can plot on a map
using things like
matplotlib and
any of those tools in this case we're
going to try uh stack stack has a handy
little uh helper function
called stackstack.show
which lets you put it onto a leaflet map
so
i'll go full screen here in a sec but as
like as i pan and zoom around uh we have
all this data out on a cluster as like
this rgb image that's in a bunch of
chunks on the cluster
and stack stack is able to say look at
what area are you looking at
and then find that window where are
those images on the cluster and then
bring back just that so
and the other thing it's able to do is
as i zoom out it's able to go to like
lower resolution up sample so that's
nice and quick
but when i zoom in
it'll snap to with the higher uh higher
resolution imagery
hopefully in just a second i'll wait for
a minute or so but there's a bunch of
computation happening on the cluster
right now
there it goes
okay
all righty
so that is an example of uh remote
sensing or a quick little um
median on some imagery um
the nice thing about x-rays like it's
this general purpose uh domain agnostic
library
so maybe you don't want to combine like
uh like
images from january with images from
july they're different seasons so you
can do things like group by time dot
month so xray has this nice high level
api for grouping and then doing
operations to each group and we're able
to build on that um for our
domain-specific application of of making
this cloud-free composite
okay so that median computation that per
month median computation finished pretty
quick and now we're pulling it back uh
locally to this uh
notebook uh the client
um and then we'll again do the uh true
color transformation from whatever units
it's in originally to rgba
um
i'm gonna skip over this section uh just
for now it's gonna take like 30 seconds
or so
but end of the day we'll get a a series
of images uh using x-ray and yeah for
one per month
um as i wait for that to actually render
i'll start to introduce the next section
just for time um uh oh i have a title
here animating hurricane florence so uh
animating yeah um so this example is
building up this uh example from pi
troll which is this library for working
with uh satellite imagery uh yeah
various satellite imagery here's our
picture so you can see snow here uh in
uh january
no snow in july say
okay great
um yeah so we're uh building out this
example from pytrol and it's going to
animate hurricane florence as it moves
across the atlantic ocean um in this
case it's going to be using data from
the goes uh satellite so goes is a
um
it's a geostationary sorry geostationary
satellite um a pair of them actually
taking pictures of the earth uh so
there's a whole bunch of information on
goes here in the uh in the data catalog
um we'll just go through this example
here
um noaa has a
storm tracks database which gives like
the positions uh and actually a whole
bunch more data for
um i think any hurricane or tropical
storm
maybe in the world we're just going to
grab out
the one for goes so it's a net cdf file
so it's like a bit difficult to
use but once you know the right storm id
which you can look up in the separate
file
um i found the storm id for for
hurricane florence um and then we can
select just the
uh data that it uses that storm id
and then xray to filter it down to just
this data for hurricane florence
so there's a whole bunch of data
variables for hurricane florence
that's tracking things even things like
wind speed and the direction we're not
going to use any of that we're just
trying to find the position of it
at some you know particular time so
we're going to grab out the time uh
attribute and then the longitude and the
latitude and we'll put that into a
geopandas
geodata frame
we can plot the data that we have so you
can see it started here over on the west
coast of africa
and made its way and we're going to be
animating this little section here
before ultimately went on to north
carolina and south carolina
okay
so this is all we need for our our uh
search that we need to find the actual
imagery okay we have our bounding box
and we have our our date time that we we
care about for this animation
so again we'll use the stack api here to
do our query in this case we're using
goes cmi the cloud and moisture imagery
passing in our bounding box which we
just discovered from that
hurricane tracks database and then the
date time
final thing here we're going to query on
so goes has several it's capturing
several different like areas and
different resolutions at the same time
so it has a picture of the whole half
disk of the earth
and then the continental united states
and then finally a mesoscale which is
kind of like a smaller zoomed in area so
we want just the mesoscale images
for this uh area and for the state time
goes is a
it has like a strange projection it's
some geostationary orbit so um we can't
use a stack stack for it so we do uh
need to use uh rio x-ray which is a
great library for reading in um
raster data into x-ray
it knows how to deal with all the weird
coordinates reference systems that gdal
can use because that's what it uses
under the hood
in this case here's the first band so we
have successfully identified the storm
we found it
and this is the blue band
all right so now we're going to read in
a bunch of data um we have several bands
here so three bands again that we're
going to read in we're going to get the
time as well
and then we're going to read this in so
for each of the time steps we have uh
three bands
so this will take uh you know 15 to 20
seconds again this is just reading in
the metadata
since it's not using stack we do have to
actually open up each of those a few
hundred files however many it is uh
maybe five yeah so uh 600 or so files
500 or 600 files
so that completed in like 12 seconds not
too bad
and then we can actually persist the
data this will actually be even slower
or faster because it's happening on our
cluster in parallel
okay uh
we're gonna make another uh pretty
picture that's not the only thing we do
but uh it's nice to make pretty pictures
so
goes doesn't have a green band but you
can use some band math to simulate it as
a combination of the red near infrared
and blue bands
so we'll call this new thing our green
band
and then
uh there's
like a gamma correction i think this
basically makes makes the picture uh
brighter a bit brighter
uh okay so we'll do that band math and
then uh normalize it gamma correction
and then compute it so that's happening
on the cluster now we have it back
locally and this will be like one of our
images
okay so that's gone from uh this uh red
near infrared uh in blue and gotten a an
rgb a red green blue image out of it
um matplotlib uh super flexible it's a
little bit of boilerplate to set up this
animation but it does what we need we're
still using like x-rays higher level
plotting apis which is great we're able
to plot onto our figure uh add some text
so this will handle like the we'll have
like a little uh text at the bottom
saying what is the current time stamp
and then we just turn through the
animation so each each time step will
we'll grab out the that slice
uh and then set the data on our image
so it doesn't take too too long to make
our image
all right just a quick heads up we have
like about five minutes left i don't see
any questions for now
great thanks
um yeah and so here is our movie
i think it's worth pausing enjoying this
for just a minute
i'm sure there's some scientific value
uh that can be gleaned from this but
it's also
like fun to look at
interesting to look at
perhaps not fun for the folks in north
carolina that this uh actually hit
okay uh so that's our our workflow there
and so yeah uh pretty picture that's
great uh probably could get some science
out of that but in terms of the actual
workflow here um i want to highlight a
couple things is like once we found the
right bounding box and the uh date time
you know is pretty straightforward to go
from that to the
um to the actual images searching for
the actual images was straightforward
using the stack api and then again we're
building on top of libraries like x-ray
and das so using those name indices was
great it's much nicer to use red near
infrared than like zero and one and
we're able to paralyze our computation
with desk
okay uh i believe that is it yeah so a
couple links here uh
planetarycomputer.microsoft.com
you can go there check out anything like
i said the stack api and the data you
can use anonymously if you want an
account on the planetary computer hub to
do that like cloud native computing uh
you can fill out an account request form
there and then the notebook that i went
through and these slides are are there
at the um at my github
cool
thank you very much tom
very exciting talk uh and we had
something to look at um mm wants to know
how much do the 64 instances use spun up
costs in azure
um i would have to check the exact uh
pricing uh the nice thing is we're using
uh spot nodes so
uh those could have been preempted by
azure if someone comes along with a
higher bid or whatever so uh it's it's
actually not too bad when you're using
spot pricing
okay uh matt wants to know general
question any thoughts on desk versus pi
spark
uh yeah i don't know i'm a das developer
so definitely biased uh here uh desk is
nice because it handles in-dimensional
arrays uh which last i checked weren't
as common in like the spark ecosystem um
and i also have not really used spark
extensively so it's hard to say i will
say the das documentation
has a pretty uh good overview of of this
exact question i'll get the link for the
chat but anyway like if i would say
both of them do similar things uh pretty
well so use you know probably whatever
you're most familiar with is a good
default position
okay and matt specifically asked for
this sort of application
yeah so um on this like so we're doing
some in-dimensional things so maybe like
that's a bit more natural in like x-ray
and desk but uh we're also you i'm sure
you could do this with spark if you
chunk it up appropriately
and there are definitely libraries nice
libraries like uh
raster frames for
uh is able to read in uh stack metadata
into its data model uh similarly to how
stack stack handles it so that from that
point of view for the stack side of
things that's uh well supported in both
cool well thanks for your talk and
thanks for being part of pi data global
2021 thank you